In today's episode, I'm going to teach
you how to talk to someone you
completely disagree with on every level.
That's looking at you, family members at
the dinner table. And here's the
takeaway I'm going to tell you right
now. You don't have to agree with them,
ever. All that more coming up. Let's go.
Welcome to the Jefferson Fisher podcast
where I'm on a mission to make your next
conversation the one that changes
everything. If you're listening to this
podcast, my guess is it's because you
want to be a better communicator and in
turn improve your life. So that's
exactly what my promise is to you. In
exchange, what I'm going to ask for is
that anywhere you're listening, would
you please press the button subscribe.
It's a very low lift, it'll take 1
second, but it really makes a difference
to me and my family and the mission that
I am continuing to serve with passion.
This episode is brought to you by Cozy
Earth. I love Cozy Earth. They've been a
sponsor of this podcast for a long time
now. Why? Because they put out really
good stuff when it comes to anything
that is cozy is the best way to put it.
And that mean the name is right on the
nose.
When I wear their sweaters, their
hoodies, the sweatpants, even just a
regular like dress pants that they look
like dress pants but they're not. Their
towels, their bedsheets, all their
products are premium. You will not
regret it. If you are somebody that is
at the age where you value a good set of
towels, you need to go to Cozy Earth.
Listen to me. Go to
cozyearth.com/jefferson,
use the code Jefferson, and get 40% off.
And now, back to the episode.
If you want to talk to someone you
completely disagree with, here's what I
want you to do. We're going to get right
to it. Number one,
don't argue the opinion, identify the
need.
Identify the need. Number two, shift
from proving to understanding.
And number three, water your own garden.
Don't waste your water trying to water
their bad seeds. All right? Water yours
and they'll get curious why yours is
doing so well. Water your own garden.
We're going to go into depth on those.
Number one,
don't argue the opinion, identify the
need. Let's go deeper on that. What does
that mean? So many times in
conversation, you are Let's say you're
at the dinner table and you have family
members, uh in-laws, whatever it is, and
somebody brings something up
and there's all of a sudden that tension
in the room. They go, "Oh god.
Oh my gosh, he They just They went
there. There they They talked about it.
They talked about that candidate. They
talked about that platform, that
opinion, that that whatever it is. Maybe
you think it's a old mindset, it's an
out-of-date mindset, it's a um it's it's
not a nice It's not good to bring up.
It's It's not cooth. Whatever it is,
it's going to bring you tension, right?
And the what you want to do is start
arguing the opinion. You're arguing the
very top, the tip of the iceberg. We get
caught in trying to argue somebody's
opinion. If they were to say, "Well, I
believe that so-and-so is the best for
this." Or they obviously this issue in
our country is the worst it's ever been.
And you want to argue, "No, it's not.
Actually, we need this." And you have
this different opinion.
You're just talking about the tip of the
iceberg. But what breaks that down is
that you're never going to get them to
come your way and you're never going to
get to theirs.
You don't have to share their
opinion
to have a valuable conversation.
What you have to do first is identify
the need.
The tip of the iceberg, what's the
bottom of it is the need. And that
usually has to do with safety
or control
or fear.
Typically fear of change.
And if you don't If you choose not to
hear their words as, "God, I cannot
believe they want to vote for that
person." Instead, you hear it as,
"They're afraid of change. They have a
fear of this. They have a fear of that."
It was told to me once that
nobody says anything for the purpose of
being wrong.
Nobody has an opinion, gives an opinion
for the purpose of being wrong.
Even the people who begin with, "You
know, I could be wrong about this." They
never think they're wrong about it, do
they?
No, they always think that they're
right. And if you go from that mindset,
instead of looking at the tip of the
iceberg, instead of the tops of the
trees, you're looking at the roots
of what is the need. It's their need for
safety
for people around them, for their own
safety. Usually it is all based in fear
and that. Or what their value is and how
for kids or for their life or how people
should do and and and live and things
that really should should have no effect
on them whatsoever, but yet they've
decided they're going to have a big
opinion on it right now.
What you're hearing is fear of change.
Things should be better. They were
always better back in the day.
If it was just how it was back when I
was a kid,
it's always a fear of change. This is
never a topic that's going to expire.
So, how do you talk to somebody you're
never going to agree with at any level?
Don't argue the opinion. That's going to
go nowhere. Instead, identify the need.
What does that sound like, Jefferson?
What does that sound like?
It sounds like you're saying, "Hey, I I
agree this is worth talking about. I You
know what? I I can hear that you really
care about the safety of this. I can
hear
uh
you don't want things to to change." Or
maybe it's as simple as,
"I hear that safety's a big thing for
you.
I hear that
this political ideal is important to
you.
I hear how
uh the future of this country is
important to you. How you begin to
simply acknowledge
the need
rather than arguing the opinion.
Another one, it sounds like you really
care about this. It sounds like you
really care about this. And you know
what they're going to say? Yeah. Yeah, I
really do. And all of a sudden you're
going to start to break down that it's
it's a deeply rooted need that they
have, typically for
control. That's That's what you're
hearing.
Don't argue the opinion.
Don't even address that. Instead,
identify the need. Ways that I even like
to
I explain that is I might say, "I agree,
but I go macro, not micro." So I might
say, "I agree this is worth talking
about. I I agree that's one way to look
at it.
I agree that's an opinion."
Or I might say, "That's helpful to know.
That's Well, you know what? That's
helpful to know."
Or I might thank them. Hey, well, thank
you for sharing that. You see how I'm
not having to agree with anything that
they said? I'm just acknowledging the
need that they have, that is deeply
rooted need. If you only respond to the
opinion,
they will argue you forever. If you only
disagree
or argue the opinion, they will
push it forever. I can promise you that
is a conversation at the dinner table
that will last months if not years
if you continue to push on that. But if
you identify and discuss and talk about
the need, the issue underneath, you can
actually make
progress. You can actually make
progress. That's where you want to go.
Number two, be more interested in
understanding rather than proving.
Proving is this mindset of, "No, you
have to agree with me. No, I have to
make you understand my way. You know
what? I I can't even
I can't even wrap my mind around how you
could possibly think this. Are you
kidding me? You actually think"
Is that ever going to make anybody agree
with you? Whenever you come on the
offensive to prove something where you
go, "A- Are you kidding me? Do you
really believe this?"
It The more you tell somebody they're
wrong, the more convinced they are that
they're right. Or they all of a sudden
clam up and go, "Well, I'm not going to
share my opinion with you. This is what
I believe. So, I don't care. Evidence
doesn't work. Facts don't work." Why?
Because you're only hitting the opinion,
you're not identifying the need like we
talked about in number one. So,
what do you do instead of trying to push
push push and prove prove prove? Cuz you
know what that feels like. What does
that do? That makes you harden even
more. Instead, ask questions that help
open up understanding. These are not
questions that begin with why.
That will kill it instantly. Well, why
do you think that? Why do you believe
that?
Uh yeah, okay.
What about anything that challenges the
why to make them explain in a defensive
posture. But if I begin with what, how,
when, where,
those are what they call open-ended
questions. Open-ended questions. So if I
were to say,
you know, "How long have you felt this
this way?"
Oh, well, you know what? I've I felt
this the first time in Oh, what what
happened there?
Where
Where did you
hear this?
You hear how I'm not going Yeah, right.
Well, okay. You explain to me how X, Y,
and Z.
That's going to clam up.
Right? But if I were to say, "Where did
you Where did you learn this?
How long have you felt that way?"
And I'm actually interested in
understanding, they will explain to you
more. And what's going to happen in that
thread? You're going to go, "Ha. Okay,
there's the the need
of something that happened to them
probably that they just believe." And
sometimes,
especially I would say in the political
area, you you see all this stuff where
they like they interview people on the
street, right? And they try and catch
them on something and they might mention
something of a different political
candidate and all of a sudden the the
person is being interviewed is talking
like they know and it's actually
inaccurate information.
It's because
people have opinions that are based on
feelings, based on the inner needs, not
typically based on facts. So, that's why
evidence doesn't work.
Proving to them, saying, "Look at this
piece of paper. How could you possibly
Look at this report that came out." That
doesn't work because it doesn't address
the inner need within. So, when you ask
the open-end questions to get them to
open up to you
and help you understand, it helps
identify the need and
it makes them feel acknowledged, it
de-escalates the situation, and it helps
have a productive conversation that
actually moves rather than just creating
a big mess where somebody has to get up
from the table and walk away because,
"You know what? I'm over this. You're
never going to change."
I want to take a quick second to tell
you about Gusto. Let's be real. Nobody
starts a business because they love
paying payroll.
I definitely didn't. And when I first
started hiring people to help me, I was
drowning in tax forms and spreadsheets
and trying to make sure everyone got
paid, right, and on time. And you want
to do the best for your people. It just
is difficult, especially if you're
running a new business. I have
personally used Gusto for four different
businesses and it's been the best
platform I could ever use. Gusto is an
online payroll and benefits software
built for small businesses. It's
all-in-one, remote-friendly, and
incredibly easy to use. So, you can pay,
hire, onboard, and support your team
from anywhere. It handles all your
taxes. If you have people remote, out of
state, it does all that for you, too.
And one of the best things about it is
that they have certified HR experts on
call for the tricky stuff, the things
you might have questions about. And you
can run unlimited payrolls for one full
flat monthly price. No hidden fees, no
surprises, just straightforward help for
people who wear a lot of hats. Try Gusto
today at gusto.com/jefferson
and get three free months when you run
your first payroll. That's three free
months, a free payroll at
gusto.com/jefferson.
One more time, gusto.com/jefferson.
And now, back to the episode. Number
three, water your own garden.
Water your own garden. I I I love this
illustration in my mind because
so much peace can be had. If If you're
somebody who gardens, you know what kind
of peace that brings up. We've had
gardens.
Um and
it is you tend to it, you pay attention
to it, you protect it, and you water it.
And so much of conversation is
understanding
I can only tell it to you. I can't
understand it for you.
So, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
water my own garden, meaning I'm going
to make sure my people are protected.
By protecting my peace, I also protect
my people. The people who care about me,
the people that need me in the right
state of mind, who who need me to be
present.
If I am so worked up about opinion of
yours that that will have no impact on
my life whatsoever at this meal or at
this gathering,
right? I'm I'm I've lost sight of the
fact that I have a beautiful garden.
If I start arguing against your opinion,
what I do is I get my water hose and I'm
all of a sudden I'm trying to water
yours. When they've planted bad seed,
and what's that going to grow?
It's going to grow thorns, it's going to
grow animosity, it's going to grow
contempt.
And all of a sudden, what could have
been a 5-minute conversation of
acknowledging the differences, there is
now 5 years of estrangement. That's what
happens. That's how quick it happens.
When you understand that they can have
their own opinion and have their garden,
let them have it and you have yours.
So, you can hear conversations from them
and say, "You know what?
I'm not trying to change your mind." Or,
"You know what? I've I know I'm not
going to change your mind. I just want
to hear what you have to say." Or, "I
appreciate what you're sharing. I know
we're not going to see the eye to eye on
this. But You know what we do make eye
to eye on?
Whatever topic
that you know that you agree on.
Choosing
when to go into that conversation,
knowing when to get out of it.
Usually, we just get very stubborn. We
get really stubborn.
And we try to go to number two, we just
prove, prove, prove, prove. And that
does nothing. So, remember when it comes
to watering your own garden,
that there will be an end to the
conversation.
And there certainly can be a place for
meaningful dialogue. What I playfully
like to say is if somebody's trying to
have some kind of conversation with me,
whether it's
is if it's something I know I disagree
with,
I might easily say, "You know what? I'd
rather hear about you."
They ask me a question that's kind of
sent to tee me up.
They ask me, "So, well, I'd rather hear
about you." Nobody gets mad
if I suggest talking about themselves.
I've never had that once. They go, "Oh."
They kind of laugh as if like, "All
right, I I understand we're not going to
go there."
And sometimes, you know, even like
my grandparent
or grandfather, you know, he will try
and spark these arguments just for fun.
They can get me really worked up and
doesn't doesn't bother him at all. Maybe
you can relate to that.
And it's me having to choose to just
water my own garden. I love him. I'll
always love him. That doesn't mean that
I have to agree with everything that he
says. Okay, what do we got? Number one,
don't argue the opinion.
Identify the need. Go deeper. Number
two,
instead of talking to prove,
talk and respond to understand.
Again, we're going layer to layer layer.
And number three, water your own garden.
Protect your own peace.
Don't be walking over and start trying
to pick their weeds.
All right?
Water your own garden.
That's the key to a lot of peace in your
life. All right. I hope you have a
wonderful holiday season. I know that's
coming up on us. And if somebody's
talking about something you completely
disagree with on every level, remember
this episode. So, you can try that and
follow me.